brillo a la mejor versión de tim y
ustedes creen que son la mejor versión
de ustedes mismo qué tal que les diría
que todavía hay tiempo para hacer la
mejor versión de ustedes mismos
lo único que tienen que hacer y ser
valientes
qué significa ser valiente bueno ser
valiente no significa no tomar riesgos
ser valiente no significa no tener miedo
ser valiente significa no dejarse
paralizar por el miedo y seguir adelante
ese miedo que muchas veces nos arropa y
nos dice y nos paraliza pero no ser
valiente es seguir adelante
y aquí les cuento algo muy personal
cuando trabajaba en mi trabajo anterior
de general motors venía regresando de mi
licencia de maternidad y mi jefe me dice
capi yo la gerente de operaciones y me
dice que a ti se nos fue el cielo y
queremos que tomen esa posición y yo no
gracias estoy feliz con lo que tengo no
quiero más
nyse capi es algo temporal te vamos a
apoyar van a ser solamente unos meses
bueno les cuento que la experiencia
terminó siendo tres años como si eso de
general motors para la financiadora acá
en caracas una tremenda experiencia y
aquí en mensajes son esas oportunidades
que si no las tomamos
entonces
que les quiero decir con esto que el
fracaso no existe
que solo tenemos resultados buenos o no
tan buenos
siempre aprendíamos porque siempre
siempre vamos a aprender algo de lo que
nos haya pasado y acá imagínense esta
posición que yo tomé me hizo prepararme
y estar en un mejor nivel para después
poder tomar la posición que tomé hace
cuatro años como country manager de
mastercard como una cosa me fue llevando
a la otra y acá el mensaje es tu mente
es una máquina de producir resultados
lo que nos pasa es realmente lo que
nosotros interpretamos fíjense en estos
temas de la pandera hay gente que dice
estoy encerrada la gente que dice y
estoy resguardado
estoy vieja hay gente que dice que estoy
en mi mejor momento para triunfar hay
gente que dice estoy agotado ya no puedo
más
estoy recargando baterías para mi
próximo triunfo para mí el próximo logro
entonces la vida no es lo que nos sucede
sino como la vemos es 10% es lo que nos
pasa y 90% es lo que nosotros
interpretamos para muchos estos han sido
tiempos
han sido tiempos de cambio y han sido
tiempos de oportunidad que les quiero
decir con esto que tú y sólo tú estás en
control de ti
y aquí el mensaje es que tal que yo
elegiría vamos a sacar mucho me van a
decir
otros van a decir es que no tengo una
pala es que las palas son muy caras
puras excusas aquí es como yo lo llamo
exquisite is a good it is que es una
inflamación de la glándula de las
excusas que produce la muerte segura del
éxito
entonces
si yo los invitara a sacar oro
ustedes
la educación es la pala que nos ayuda a
sacarse ahora la gente de éxito estudia
de una a tres horas diarias invierte de
unas tres horas diarios en prepararse en
lo que hace en prepararse en su
profesión en cada vez saber más tú
cuántas horas estudias en lo que tú
haces cuántas horas te preparas bueno
recuerda tú estás donde estás hoy por lo
que hiciste
y estarás mañana por lo que hagas y
dejes de hacer ahora
como dice mi gran amigo albert eisntein
si buscamos resultados distintos
no hagas lo mismo siempre
fíjense en estos temas de la pandemia
como las compañías innovando y cambiando
cosas que nunca habíamos pensado lo han
hecho diferente la cantidad de gente que
está trabajando ahora te lo working las
cantidades reuniones que tenemos por son
los eventos como esta que estamos
haciendo virtualmente como de alguna
otra manera hemos innovado entonces
empieza empieza hoy mismo piensa que
nunca va a haber un momento perfecto
para hacer las cosas nunca va a haber un
momento perfecto para tener una familia
para tener hijos para tener un mejor
trabajo y así la lista puede ser enorme
el momento es eso en el momento es
ahorita es atreverse es ser valiente
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos
convierten en la mejor versión de ti
mismo y empieza ahora gracias